noi abbiamo due casi in sicilia
all'interno dello stesso giardino io non
dormo in una giammarco dorme nell'altra
insieme a un sacco di altri fratelli e
cugini indovinate dove norme guglielmo
nella casa dove non succede
cos'è successo il panico ciao ragazzi
ben tornati alla nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
esperienze paranormali per un tema così
importante ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios dei casa mia
una persona che possiamo definire un
professionista una persona che ha un
rapporto con lo spiritismo l'esoterismo
l'astrologia veramente veramente forte
il problema è che questa persona non era
disponibile quindi ho preso il primo che
ho incontrato per strada e ho buttato
all'interno di questo tema mio cugino
gian marco salve a tutti allora lo sa
che un sacco di persone che volevano
all'interno degli studios
mi chiedo perché anch'io ma non ho
trovato una risposta che mi chiedo il
perché tu mi abbia invitato nell'unica
puntata dove ci si approcciano perché in
realtà già mi alle persone non lo sanno
ma noi veniamo da una famiglia molto
molto molto particolare a lui è uno dei
portatori di uno dei grandi segreti
della mia famiglia c'è una roba che ha
coinvolto la maggior parte dei miei
parenti non me perché non c'ero sai di
cosa sto certo va bene dimenticare quei
giorni senza comprare che gianmarco è
l'addetto di vita buttata voi non lo
sapete ma la selezione che viene fatta
forse era già detto in passato dei primi
commenti
i primi grazie che arrivano da fa lui in
modo da riuscire a prendere proprio
quelli più giusti che poi riesco a
sentire insieme all'ospite in maniera
assolutamente spontanea per la prima
volta parrebbe vengono ancora
selezionati ed è la prima volta che il
tu non hai ascoltato i commenti ai post
la mito haifa lo strano di sovranità è
vero che la troupe ha ingaggiato sia
all'altezza
così sarò molto obiettivo è severo
analisi perché è tanto facile
momento delicato massimo ora io sono
molto scettico
io sono contrario invece succede certo
ho le mie credenze non ci scherza sopra
anche quando la realtà è troppo
paranormale che cos'è appena cara dietro
manco ci scherzo però ecco pronto il
piano era un piccoli e avevamo una di
queste prime macchine fotografiche
digitali no allora scegliamo di farci
una foto gela sarà quindi con flash
dietro c'era una sedia di quelle bianche
di plastica quelle classiche diciamo
scattiamo questa quota tutti a vedere
come è venuta vediamo che in questa
serie a c'era una sagoma di una persona
seduta ma era perfetta c'era proprio una
persona allora tutti ci giriamo di
scatto per questa sedia che si era
praticamente girata e poi non mi ricordo
chi forse mia sorella
presa dal panico cancello la foto spagna
ha chinato grafica poi siamo rimasti
tutti in silenzio traumatizzati da
questa roba non l'abbiamo fatto
scaldate non me la scorderò nemmeno dai
ragazzi dovesse capitarmi in morirei su
konko riuscire nemmeno a premere e
cancella voto per cancellare in e
dall'abyan e rivas e lorenza sta ragazza
mi sa che se molto in ascolto in questa
terra tanto inibendo
io da piccola vivevo in un ato in
montagna di quelle vecchissime no quando
non c'era nessuno si tornava si trovava
sportelli aperti oppure insomma sentiva
rumore robe del genere durante la notte
dalla soffitta si sente piangere tipo
cicciobello quelle bomber insomma minor
tempo angolo sì che la mattina il babbo
va in soffitta per togliergli le
batterie torna sotto bianchissimo perché
in realtà non aveva le batterie il male
quale doveva essere come in chi progetta
questi giocattoli che si anche mia
moglie ma che cos'è sì ma perché devi
fare un bambino che piange fare che ride
no
la vecchia dei nostri sia piramide una
casa c'era una razza è stato una sera il
pianoforte che ha iniziato a suonare
piano le ragazze tin tin tin tin così
ecco perché sono stato quando sei
piccolo i grandi della canzone tipo no
allora ti spiego delle onde
elettromagnetiche ha fatto suonare il
pianoforte stai tranquillo non è il
piano porta adesso bruciato che mi è
capitata quand'ero bambina la notte mi
sono svegliata è in lacrime quando mi
sono svegliata ho sentito dei rumori
ho pensato che mia madre sentendo col
suo re c'era da piangere il sito stesso
tratto il vigile a kazan harvey quindi
mi sono alzato dal letto e ne sono
andata diciamo incontro la mia camera e
alla fine di un corridoio e volevo
andare a per ombra del corridoio una
sagoma bianca che poteva somigliare
molto quella di mia madre perché metteva
queste camicie da notte è chiaro allora
io la chiamo le vado incontro
mamma mamma però arriva la città non c'è
niente assolutamente niente mia mamma
che rossa la sua camera io ho analizzato
anche che comincia a tremare è un certo
punto sento sulla mia mano una specie di
carezza no c'è quella notte ho bagnato
il letto complimenti che l'ha solo
bagnarlo di chicago che magari perché
siamo mandi ragazzi sfide io prima di
fare alle superiori ogni mattina mentre
potevo la porta di casa sentivo dei
bambini e mi salutavano ho chiesto a mia
madre che cosa sarebbe potuto essere e
le ambientazioni dei sentimenti e di
nives i bambini e quindi un giorno lei
mi disse guarda prova non salutarli un
giorno li ho salutati io mentre usciva
di casa e dopo giorno all'occhio sentiti
ma zio materno ma la ma io se mio figlio
mi disse mi sa dire papa da sotto i
bambini che ricorda
attendiamo area da mia cugina per quindi
niente abbiamo un'altra persona che mira
a farci sostegno e volevo raccontare di
quella volta in cui ero in polonia a
casa di mia mamma
ad un certo punto è tutto spento in
camera con la porta aperta a un mero
piano di sotto il piano sui sopra i
sentieri dei passi forti sulle scale
controllo chi c è sulle scale sassari
mia donna non c'era nessuna era tutto
buio e santo questi passi e mia nonna
giu di sotto furla ma che stai facendo
su di sopra
abbiamo controllato tutta la casa per
vedere se ci fossero adrio che guardiamo
se ci fossero ladri se era entrato
qualcuno tra non si sapeva era casa era
totalmente chiusa quindi insomma non
poteva essere entrato nessuno e ridono
jazz enrico cosa che posso vivere
[Musica]
noi abbiamo due casi in sicilia
all'interno dello stesso giardino io non
dormo in una giammarco dorme nell'altra
insieme a un sacco di altri fratelli e
cugini indovinate dove norme guglielmo
nella casa dove non succede niente
cosa è successo il panico
fondamentalmente questa casa a due piani
e le scale quando tu sali scritto erano
per cui tu senti chiaramente quando star
ii piano all'interno di una delle stanze
quando sta salendo qualcuno e poi
diciamo che nel disimpegno anche nelle
scale dovresti vedere comparire la
persona quando fa proprio l'ultimo
l'ultimo scalino sotto ma loro non la
vedevano mai era molto poi c'eravamo io
e gli altri tuoi fratelli c'era un
periodo che non so per quale motivo io
leggevo harry potter ad alta voce ma
come ninna nanna per i tuoi fratelli
erudito in quella stanza
pensa un po ricorda siamo capaci di
leggere diciamo in quella stanza quindi
leggeri leggevo già c'erano stati dei
campanelli di allarme tipo ragazzi ma
per caso ogni tanto sentiti dei rumori
sulle scale percepite qualche strano
rumore qualcosa del genere
sì cioè di base è stato un sì unanime
però l'esperienza che vi racconterò è
una testimonianza di tutti noi
contemporaneamente
chiaramente poi sentite i passi sulle
stato io stavo leggendo tua immagine di
come se senti qualcuno che sale
ci alziamo andiamo a vedere gabriele
aveva un mitra carne 47 ma di quelli
finti con italease
siamo arrivati a un punto che gabriella
e ogni volta che sentiamo i rumori
usciva colmi 3 cominciava a sparare
sotto alle scale osb aster e la fase
successiva era impasticcarsi di
valeriana per andare a dormire ma ce ne
stanno tante facciamo notte s'eleva
xenon e abbiamo avere ragazzi
noi abbiamo storie di spiritismo perché
in sicilia in quel periodo evidentemente
andava di moda fare sedute spiritiche
noi se facciamo una storia su instagram
allora evocavano porto buona fermati
sono testimoni di sedute spiritiche
diciamo siamo una famiglia un po
particolare per chi non l'avesse capito
anzi per un periodo eravamo gli addams
la versione simulato un terremoto ma che
è sì velocissimo fortissimo come se
qualcuno stesse cercando qualcosa che
niente
lei può essere addormentata preso una
sega elettrica si è avuta la rete gas è
riuscita a me la serie procurato ripresa
che solamente un coltellino e avrei
demolito il letto sventrato il materasso
e dormito scusate la pietra che bevo il
ventilatore e sempre nella sempre in
quella camera dove stavamo tutti noi
come voce questo è lunga si è alzato
nella notte e il ventilatore acceso mai
raccontata deve non me la rivista
granata spegnere lo spegne il tempo di
non era a letto
sento il tasto del ventilatore che viene
premuto classico tocco fatta girare il
ventilatore e lui sa che a fascio
un aspetto il nuovo male baci al
ventilatore che sappia in acceso ritorna
ci proverà di nuovo a spegnerle dire dai
seri succedono seconda volta però c'è
qualcosa non torna bravo cioè capito io
voglio vedere se funziona sotto ma mi
sale pure una cosa di potere non è
possibile che ora c'è lo spirito che
magari che spirito è il gioco del
legislatore con lo spirito cioè vieni
dalla di lava viene a giocare con
ventilatore perdonami ma siccome spirito
riesce a superare i piani per accenderli
ventilatore hai visto mai visto ghost
che esercizio devono fare i fantasmi per
il sì e lei sa di poter che esercizio
nel fare per lanciare avada kedavra
stasera succederà qualcosa sono troppo
sprezzante nei confronti dell'altro
pare che questo video sta diventando
veramente come come la cassetta di the
ring secondo me le persone che guardano
a un certo punto ricevono è chiamata lo
posteremo non lo so tra come sette
giorni la seconda parte del video la
mettiamo giovedì prossimo sempre alle 14
ore nicácio tre ore di ave maria attesi
dolore e riprendiamo dato ascoltarli
perché sennò non arriviamo a domani io
mi faccio di guar che grazie ad esse
rimasti qui per il momento rimaniamo
così sospesi nel frattempo iscrivetevi e
attivate la notifica per non perdere il
video alla prossima settimana
ciao sette giorni